das kennen wir alle von star trek und
tatsächlich ist wie möglich zunächst mal
mit quantenzuständen und das gilt auch
als die schlüsseltechnologie für quanten
kommunikationsnetzwerke doch das große
problem bislang ist man hierbei immer
noch weitestgehend auf den zufall
angewiesen
doch damit ist jetzt schluss einem
österreichischen forschungsteam gelang
nämlich ein spektakulärer erfolg und ob
und wann das beamen von menschen möglich
ist das erfahrt ihr jetzt in science
fiction
hier gibt es jeden tag spannende
wissenschafts videos aber nicht den
kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen beamen oder
teleportation wie es auch genannt wird
ist ja wohl bei weitem das beste
transportmittel was man sich überhaupt
vorstellen kann
in der theorie gibt es gleich zwei
möglichkeiten die die teleportation
möglich machen könnten
dazu müsste eine person entweder in
daten übertragen werden um dann am
gewünschten zielort wieder zu einer
physischen masse verwandelt zu werden
oder aber die masse müsste am
ausgangsort komplett abgebaut werden und
dann am gewünschten ort wieder
rekonstruiert werden
auch wenn das erste mal total
unrealistisch klingt ist das in der
theorie sogar mit den gesetzen der
physik vereinbar konkret geht es dabei
um das phänomen der sogenannten
quantenverschränkung vereinfacht gesagt
teilen sich hierbei zwei teilchen den
selben zustand und das obwohl eine große
distanz zwischen ihnen liegt
forschungsteams weltweit setzen große
hoffnung in diese technik denn darauf
basierende quanten
kommunikationsnetzwerke könnte das in
zukunft möglich machen auch über sehr
große distanzen hundertprozentig sicher
verschlüsselte nachrichten zu übertragen
in dem prozess werden verschränkte paare
von photonen benötigt diese stammen aus
nichtlinearen kristallen in denen ein
einziges buch energetisches photonen in
zwei verschränkte photonen niedrigerer
energie aufgespalten wird doch der
zufall stellte diesen forschungsbereich
noch für eine riesige herausforderung
denn er alleine entschied bislang
darüber wann ein geeignetes photon paar
entsteht technologische umsetzung waren
somit bislang wenn überhaupt nur
eingeschränkt möglich ein forschungsteam
aus linz ist es jetzt aber gelungen den
zufall bei diesem prozess
zu umgehen in ihrem experiment schaffte
es die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler verschränkte photonen
quasi auf knopfdruck zu erzeugen konkret
nutzen sie winzige quantenpunkte
eingebettet in halbleiter kristallen
dazu wurde ein aluminium galliumarsenid
kristall verwendet in dessen oberfläche
ein symmetrisches loch gehetzt wurde
aufgefüllt wurde es mit reinem
galliumarsenid somit schaffte das
forschungsteam eine hohe symmetrie und
reinheit der quantenpunkte was ihn
letztendlich wohl auch zu ihrem erfolg
verhalf in ihrem experiment legten sie
die quantenpunkte durch laserpulse an
und brachten sie somit dazu zwei
verschränkte photonen abzugeben dazu
einer der beteiligten forscher markus
reindel das funktioniert im grunde auf
knopfdruck jeder laserpuls erzeugt mit
90-prozentiger wahrscheinlichkeit ein
photonen paar
das wären dann für die teleportation
nutzen können somit wurden tatsächlich
kannten objekte on demand erfolgt laut
den angaben des forschungsteams weltweit
eine premiere auch wenn es noch einige
schwachpunkte zu beheben gibt einige
photonen werden kurz nach ihrer
erzeugung von dem system verschluckt was
natürlich nachteil darstellt das
ergebnis jedenfalls macht große hoffnung
auf einen technologischen einsatz von
quantenpunkten in naher zukunft dies
würde die quantenkommunikation wiederum
einen riesigen schritt nach vorne
bringen
für die teleportation wie wir sie aus
filmen wie star trek kennen bedeutet
dies allerdings keinen wirklichen
fortschritt um diese umzusetzen und wenn
es nur um ein winziges staubkorn geht
sind unsere technischen möglichkeiten
bisher einfach noch längst nicht
ausgereift genug ein britisches
forschungsteam hatte vor einigen jahren
einmal grob überschlagen dass das beamen
eines menschen nicht nur millionen jahre
dauern würde sondern dass auch der stand
der technik heutzutage nicht wirklich
zuletzt diese person sinnvoll von
standort zu standort b zu übertragen
wenn die teleportation bräuchte einfach
eine viel zu enormen datenmenge
die nächste große frage wäre außerdem ob
man diesen prozess überhaupt überleben
könnte und wäre die personen nach der
teleportation überhaupt noch dieselbe
trotz dieser vielen unzähligen ungelöste
aspekte zu diesem thema gibt es einige
fachleute die dennoch optimistisch sind
dazu gehört beispielsweise der
us-physiker michalkow der davon ausgeht
dass es uns menschen spätestens im
nächsten jahrhundert gelingt und zu
teleportieren bot ja wenn ihr die ersten
sein wollen die davon erfahren dann
folgt mehr auf whatsapp dann da bekommt
er also hier klicken
da bekommt ihr alle infos vor allen
anderen exklusiv von mir persönlich
einfach draufklicken und ganz wichtig
meine nummer unbedingt in euren
kontakten abspeichern wir hören und
sehen und schreiben uns dort bis dann
bleibt dran